it's not even februari but we've already  gotten a glimpse of what Rockstar is  planning for grand theft auto online  Valentine's Day update if you like  american gangster cars and suits you're  in for a treat thanks to some good  old-fashioned data mining GTA 5 players  have uncovered some new content within  the game's code the big addition seems  to be the Roosevelt Valor a new version  of the classic card images of pinstripe  suits have also surfaced on Twitter and  a reference to a new game mode is also  buried in the code though we don't know  any details about it looks like we'll  have to wait for rock stars official  announcement the Valentine's Day update  comes hot on the heels of the new drop  zone game type so there's no shortage of  GTA online content out there you can  read all about it on gamespot then when  rock star reveals the next batch of new  stuff you'll already be in the right  place